foreign
for many people you know
spending time in a dreamy location looks
like this
but for me it looks like this
as a natural product chemist I've always
been inspired by those wonderful
chemical substances we found in nature
especially
chemicals that are made by living
organisms from cold environments
and today
I want to bring you along my incredible
journey into discovering the molecular
treasure hiding in plants and other
organisms thriving in the cold
okay now I know what you might be
thinking
Norman
this just isn't for me
chemistry was my worst subject in school
and I hate being cool why on Earth
should I keep listening
to which I say stay with me because I'm
convinced that there's some amazing
chemicals hiding in the north which
perhaps means that the next wonder drug
to treat some of the nasty diseases that
plings us human is just waiting to be
discovered
but we might not Discover it without URL
are you intrigued now
good
but before we go on with the chemistry I
want to give you a quick geography
lesson
when we talk about the Canadian North we
talk about the land which is north of
the 55th parallels
this includes most of the parts of
Nunavik and Nunavut
and this land is really famous for
beautiful landscape
it's famous for polar bear
it's famous for Northern Lights and it's
famous for
Santa Claus
but despite these famous icons
they're great white snowy Nord is still
largely an explorer and that's
especially true at the molecular level
and my team and I hypothesize that
Northern ecosystem must be producing
fantastic unknown chemical
with fascinating properties
why
because of the Irish conditions and the
unique stressors plant fungi and other
organism are experiencing in the north
they must produce chemical to protect
themselves from these stresses
for example imagine the sunburn you
would get
sunbathing for over 20 hours a day for a
month
well to survive you will need a
tremendously good sunscreen that's
exactly what lichens have in Northern
ecosystem
to protect themselves
from UV irradiations they fabricate
defense chemical that blocks UV ray with
an outstanding efficiencies
and that's only one of the defense
chemicals we know about
and we believe
that there are many many more hiding up
there and couple years ago my group and
I began our endeavors to prove this
now let me bring you to umuac Nunavik a
small Inuit Village on the coast of the
Hudson Bay
and
we were interested there we collected
and we looked at the grayish lichens
that have been very scarcely
investigated
now this lichens is found only in
ecosystem with very harsh climate
conditions
and
almost nothing was known at that time on
its chemical content so we thought it
was a great species to investigate
so even though serial current pascali is
quite abundant in Nunavik
we always try to minimize our footprint
so we sample only 100 gram of the
lichens and we brought it back to our
lab at University level in Quebec City
there we've cleaned it and then we
crushed it at minus 190 degrees Celsius
using liquid nitrogen and this step is
essential to release the natural
substances within the Lycan cell
we then transfer the sample in the form
of Paul using different solvents in a
process called maceration
and after we filter the sample and
evaporated the solvents and we obtain
what we call
a crude lichen extract and for natural
product chemists that's when the funds
start
true careful chromatographic separation
and many other techniques and years of
work we've been able to separate purify
and identify for the first time ever 13
natural substances in Stereo Columbus
now I know your minds are exploding
right now
but wait there's more
from these 13 natural substances turned
out that 11
were already been identified in other
Legends but two of the substances turned
out to be unique in the world
think about it for a moment
from over 340
000 natural chemical substances known on
the planet
is producing two unique substances
a clear demonstration
that organism experiencing stresses in
Northern ecosystem produces unique
chemicals
now what are the properties of these
chemical
of these natural substances we don't
know at this point this is still under
investigation and to me and I hope to
you now
this is the exciting part
who knows in the next generation of much
needed anti-inflammatory agent or
cancer-fighting drug or even pure for
Alzheimer's
will be inspired by a chemical substance
from a new navigance
wow
let me bring you now further north
in Nunavut
on the beautiful Baffin Island
and here the story began when a group of
Canadian microbiologists identified for
the first time ever in the sediment of
the beautiful Cold rubbisher Bay a
macroscopic fungus
well the fungus was part of the genius
of what we call mortierellas and so they
call it with not much originality
mozzarella
but they also discover that this weird
looking fungus
is synthesizing unique natural
substances the mortimites
now why a rather
strange looking fungus is producing
these natural substances is still a
mystery however
this spark our curiosity
from past research investigation we knew
that natural substances that share some
of the similarities with the marchamide
compound isolated from the jetrofa
plants from Africa and and team malaria
properties
because they were able to neutralize the
parasite responsible for the majority of
malaria cases
could the marchamide possess the same
properties
well to find out we went back to the lab
and we synthesized sufficient quantity
of all the martianides and we studied
their
anti-malaria activity and guess what
are the substances the mortem ID
efficiently neutralize
parasite of malaria
but that not the end of story it's even
better
it was able to neutralize
a strain of the parasite that is
resistant to many many malaria drugs
currently used in the clinic
isn't that amazing
you get the natural substances coming
out from me produced by a macroscopic
fungus isolated from the sediment of the
icicle from the survey in the great
white snowy north
that could provide an answer
to one of the most terrible tropical
infections
It's a Small World After All
isn't it
well it's time to talk about the scary
news
the north unfortunately is undergoing
transformation at an alarming pace
it is warming up faster than anywhere
else on the planet
and this leads to a phenomenon called
The Greening of Northern ecosystem
and this is particularly true with
Nunavik
and with terrorism
shrub called bitulog landolosa that is
progressing North very rapidly
now one of the immediate consequences of
this rapid shrub growth is that it
decrees the daylight on all lower plants
and legends
this is altering the complete food chain
and it's altering also the traditional
way of living of indigenous communities
and unavoidably this will lead to loss
of biodiversity
and one of the Hidden consequences of
losing biodiversity is the loss of chemo
diversity
it is my great fear that with the loss
of plants like him and fungus some
unknown fascinating natural substances
and potentially wonder drug could be
lost to
now
this is why we think our work is
important
And Timely
and this is why I hope by now you're
convinced that you have a good reason to
help protect the great white snowy north
for my part
I'm going to continue to search for
molecular treasure in the North in the
hope of finding novel arguments to
provide stakeholders and politicians
with good arguments or
enforcing stronger and immediate measure
to mitigate climate change
for your part
remember the story of Martin D and now a
discovery in the North
could save lives in the Tropic
We're All in This Together
and no matter what corner of the planets
you lived in you must do your part to
save motherhood
one molecule at the time merci beaucoup
thank you
[Applause]